most young scientists are eager to know
how to become successful the key
qualities of a successful scientist and
the secret formula for success
so what makes a good scientist
i ask google
scientists are patient as they repeat
experiments multiple times to verify
results
we have to be courageous we fail a lot
must be open-minded it's about learning
from failures
but that's the things you already knew
what does it really take to be not just
a scientist but a great scientist
and what can we learn from those who
came before us and what does it really
take to be a great scientist in today's
age
where we have all sorts of fancy tools
that would make all of our predecessors
pretty envious
so firstly how are we defining a good or
shall i say great scientists
well this is a contentious topic
should it be based on publication counts
number of citations impact factor
impact of what what journal
translatability life saved
an alternative is to look at the
qualities of good scientists and
according to this article there are 10
qualities that define successful
scientists
not all accomplished scientists will
possess all of these qualities but most
will have many of the qualities
it includes passionate about his or her
career resilience
detail-oriented yet visionary a creative
thinker determined
knowledgeable a team player
self-motivated
an effective communicator
well thank you
capable of thinking outside of the box
so where is the evidence for this list
that is what a good scientist would say
well i put some familiar faces on my
thumbnail sharing some successful
scientists
so let's take a look at some of them
what they did and what we can learn from
them as scientists
example number one
rutherford
going against predictions
ionus rutherford contributed to our
understanding of the structure of the
nucleus
not my favorite kind of nucleus but this
one the one that makes up atoms
the center with protons and neutrons
that are surrounded by electrons
anyway it was while i was recently
reading this book foundations thus i
re-learned how
rather than made his grand discovery
rutherford was firing an alpha particle
beam at gold foil the actual experiments
were done by hans geiger and ernest
marsden with rather directing but anyway
their assumption based on the current
plum pudding model of the atom was that
the beam was all passed through like if
you threw a dart at some tissue paper
but to that surprise they saw particles
reflected and were like
it showed that their prediction or the
previous predictions of the structure
were incorrect
they were proven wrong but they were
willing to accept that they were wrong
and trust the data
and rutherford then hypothesized that
the positive charge of the atom was
concentrated in the tiny nucleus and
that most of the atom's volume was empty
space
so the data drives rational thinking
about what is happening and what should
be done next
and so all of this is great but only
great if you can trust your data what if
they had set up the detector incorrectly
how do you come to trust your data
well we'll touch on tools later in this
video but another way you can trust your
data is knowing that you have had the
correct controls and tried to answer the
same question using different techniques
from different perspectives
and who better to look at their mendel
since it's now been 200 years since his
discoveries
greg or mendel through a series of
cross-breeding experiments in pea plants
showed that traits can be inherited and
that they were inherited by elements or
determinants
there was no blending of traits
with the data mendel collected he
recognized that the formation of
reproductive cells and the process of
fertilization explained his segregation
ratios
now mental wasn't the first to study
patterns of inheritance
but he was the first to use true
breeding strains as the parents and to
quantify his results
the traits he studied were simple
well-defined characteristics or
phenotypes like round or wrinkled seeds
yellow or green seeds
mendel's experiments were quantitative
and perhaps it's with his background in
physics as well as plant physiology that
encouraged him to look at the ratios and
see that the genetic ratios were the
same this three to one segregation
pattern
and independent of the traits that she
was analyzing
and so he designed these experiments so
that the answers sort of became obvious
and with the information you can then
rethink your hypothesis to explain the
data
mendel's presence deduction of pad
elements that break up their association
and separate into different daughter
cells is what makes him the founder of
genetics
but it was also time that enabled them
to make these discoveries
so patience was also key
but do these lessons still apply to 21st
century science
well now we'll move from genetics to
gene editing and to the nobel prize
winners for chemistry in 2020 jennifer
daudner and emmanuel charpentia
which they were rewarded for their work
developing the crispr cast 9 gene
editing tools
it has and continues to have wider
reaching applications
charpentia identified the rna components
of the machinery and this caught the
attention of downer who was studying rna
now i haven't done i read them full
justice here but you can read full
details about this discovery in a couple
of books now so if interested you should
check those out
but what stands out in this example was
their creativity and their experimental
skills and also again their good
experimental design that led them to
elucidate the biochemical activity of
the cath9 enzyme and how it could be
applied to actual gene editing and after
that it's a very nice research paper
and so that brings us to today and how
do we go about making more good
scientists
well we have many tools at our disposal
these days such as crispr progemics
genomics metabolomics
fancy microscopes
however at least in biology we must
generate ideas as well as data argus
poor nurse another nobel prize winner
for uncovering components of the cell
cycle
researchers should know why the data is
being collected what hypotheses are
being tested
and what ideas are emerging and if i may
add it's important to remember that
despite our fancy techniques
many of them still have limitations so
it is important to not solely depend on
one method for an answer
now i could talk a while about my advice
for a phd but i will hold back now until
i actually get mine and publish my
research as who am i really to say all
this
am i a good scientist
well my citation score etc is definitely
not great but i don't think i'm a bad
scientist
and by no means is it a dichotomy
believe it or not i could still be more
organized more critical and more focused
but i would also say if i was just
cloned and everyone was like me
scientific progress would also be
stifled it's the differences and
perspectives and collaborations with
different minds and techniques that move
science forwards
and of course good experimental design
get those controls in there
but if you're not happy with my answers
well lucky you wiki how has an 11 step
guide on how to be a good scientist but
youtube thinks you'd rather watch this
video here
and so i hope you've learnt something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening